David known him since before SNL met him
when he came in he was always cool you
met him before that yeah he was like 21
I was like 30 or something and did you
guys seem did he seem similar to you
kind of
um there was a period of time where yeah
he was like definitely from My Tribe you
know we have us you know there's there
was a time when he opened for me so he's
like 28 29 I'm like 38 and we he'd come
out and we were playing these sheds in
the round in uh the Northeast and he'd
walk out and they'd go from a lot wide
shot at that point they thought it was
me you know and so but they're like oh
no no Spade was so hip even then
eventually he just had shorts on a
skateboard and he would kind of just
hang over the stool and he's like what's
up everybody I go I had this you can do
it that way I didn't know you could do
with that way and he was hysterical
because I come out jumping around isn't
that special you know I drenching
sweating this page it's cool he's got a
little diet ever see what's up ladies
you know yeah so he's the coolest but
really fun to do a podcast with him he
can drop a little sketch in five seconds
he can go he can take a story of just
that the hamburger was overcooked the
guy's going I'm like
hey buddy could you a little bit on the
boat I mean he'll create a complete
sketch in five seconds so it's so much
fun to watch it's so Lo-Fi he doesn't
push it at all you got to go back and
Rewind it almost yeah yeah that's a
remarkable way to say him it's like he
like just he's not out there barking
about his prayers it's just like hey
come see what I made he's got this
little physical moves that's that
represent another person a little effect
and really funny word packages hey buddy
foreign
you know
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one